when I was a boarding school
sent away doing with war as a little boy
I had a sense of imprisonment and
powerlessness and I longed for movement
and power superhuman power and ease of
movement I enjoy these briefly and
dreams of flying and in a different way
when I went horse riding in the village
air school I loved the power and
suppleness of my horse and I can still
evoke it's easy
joyous movement its warmth and sweet a
nice smell most of all I love motor
backs my father had one before the war
Ascot flying squirrel with a big
water-cooled engine and an exhaust like
a scream and I wanted a powerful bike -
by the time I was 14 it was understood
that I was going to be a doctor
my mother and father were both
physicians and so a my two older
brothers
I was not sure however but I wanted to
be a doctor I could no longer nourish
ambitions to be a chemist chemistry
itself had advanced there beyond the
18th and 19th century in organic
chemistry they loved so much
but a 14 or 15 inspired by my school
biology teacher and by Stein bits
cannery row I thought I would like to
become a marine biologist when I got my
scholarship to Oxford
I faced a choice should I stick to
zoology or become a pre-med student and
do anatomy biochemistry and physiology
it was especially the physiology of the
senses the fascinated me how did we see
color depth movement how did we
recognize anything how do we make sense
of the world
visually I had developed these interests
from an early age through having visual
migraines for beside the brilliant
zigzags which heralded an attack I might
during an attack lose the sense of color
or depth or movement or even the ability
to recognize anything
my vision could be unmade deconstructed
in front of me
and then bv made we have swapped it on
the space of a few minutes
incidentally I think this was why I love
my first book on migraine and devoted a
third of it to visual migraine I knew
where of I wrote
I'm Robert Krulwich I'm a reporter cover
lots of science things I meant Oliver
because he was lying down and I was
standing up he had broken his leg after
having missed his leg for a long period
the guy was like a mess he had lost his
leg to his brain he'd found his leg and
then broken it again and now I was lying
in a room in Einstein's Medical Center
in the Bronx and a friend of mine said I
was working at the time for all things
considered NPR so there's this older guy
up in the Bronx who's like the best
storyteller ever he had had I find hard
to speak in the past and he had a talent
for beauty that I've rarely run into
there is beauty all over in the world
even in the most troubled places but it
takes a special kind of person to see
the beauty here and then there and there
and to write it down and then somehow in
translation it becomes more beautiful
and that that's the essence of it for me
is that he took he found the beauty and
then rendered it even more beautiful The
Listening act was an empathic act almost
always if you just parade the people
that he chose to look at people who are
autistic people who were color blind
people who couldn't hear people who had
lost their sight gain their sight and
lost it again
people who were Toretto's people who
were hallucinating all the time you
parade these people and then you add
Oliver and all Oliver does is he makes
them so real and so familiar that you
lose the sense of them being other and
then if a Harold Pinter or Robin
Williams or another great artist reads
these accounts and decides to make a
movie or a play
about what Oliver's written about then
more people hear about these folks and
the narrative just moves out from Oliver
into the world and the end result is
that and this is rare to say about
anyone any doctor in artist that the
world gains new friends through the act
of intimately sitting with these people
and making them your friend then the
friendship level expands because poets
do it
playwrights do it then all of a sudden
everybody can do it my name is Robert
Klinsmann and I'm a professor of
psychiatry here at Columbia University I
at one point here in New York saw Oliver
at a party and introduced myself and we
talked and I mentioned I just written a
book called in a house of dreams and
glass becoming a psychiatrist and Oliver
said oh I'd love to see it I sent him a
copy of the book thinking well it's very
nice he's a big name I'll never hear
from him but that's okay and then I
received a long handwritten letter from
him in look like blue crayon and he said
he loved the book and said that your
writing is quote both light and deep at
the same time well Oliver affected my
work in my life in several ways perhaps
the most important is that he created a
precedent for things that I and others
have then later done that was much
easier to do because Oliver had paved
the way it's one of the works I read was
Oliver's work a leg to stand on which
came out before the man who mistook his
wife for a hat it's not one of the books
that Oliver is most known for it's
probably his least known book or one of
his two or three least known books but
was about his own experience as a
patient and I always felt that that was
important for Oliver's development so
it's not just that he had a gift for use
of words for use of language for for
being able to tell the story of
someone's life of someone dealing with
whatever kind of neurologic problem for
lack of a better term they may have
if it were patient for instance but he
had this wonderful sensibility to look
at not just the brain and the neurology
of it but the anthropology of it the
whole humaneness of it
I'm Brian Greene here in the flesh the
ie I first met Oliver Sacks about 17
years ago it was when my first book the
elegant universe had just come out and I
was invited to what you might call my
first literary gathering so there are a
lot of writers in the room at this
dinner I recognize a lot of science
writers books that I had read but then I
spotted Oliver across the room
and it was he who I really wanted to
meet because look I have and had great
respect for science writers that's a
very important thing to do but to write
about the afflicted those who society
for so long has kept under the radar
those who can make us uncomfortable and
to find the beauty and the humanity and
the grace in their stories and make us
care about these individuals want to
know about these individuals feel
compelled to read about these
individuals and allow us to catch our
breath at the surprising sometimes
debilitating wondrous poetic qualities
that can emerge from but a small
variation in the same handful of gray
matter that we all have inside our heads
that wasn't science writing that was a
ferocious Talent and a rare gift so I'm
in this room sort of in this awestruck
starstruck State and Oliver over
cocktails turned to me
said that that very day he'd finished
reading my book and I I kept my
composure but inside I was like [ __ ]
that's amazing right and then he goes on
and said how he was so thrilled to learn
about what's happening at the cutting
edge of unified theories again I was
like wow this is amazing and then he
said but the book itself is a little
slippery
and I was like whoa you know so I was
about to kind of launch into well you
know even we professional physicists we
find quantum mechanics slippery too you
know and he said no no Brian Brian what
I mean is the book is literally slippery
I I was reading it in the tub and the
hardcover just slipped right out of the
jacket into and he says I'm I'm probably
the first person to have already bought
two copies of your book No
so the next the next time we cross paths
oliver night across paths it was
actually in May of 2008 at the first
world science festival because as as
Tracy said Oliver was a great friend of
the festival you know he year after year
would sit in a chair just like this
oftentimes on this very stage but the
encounter that really sticks in my mind
did happen at that first inaugural
festival it wasn't an event that took
place here it was an event that took
place at the Abyssinian Baptist Church
on a hundred and thirty eight Street it
was anyone at that event anyone in here
two people it's very good yes excellent
there were actually two thousand people
at this event up there in 2008 I mean
Tracy Dana were absolutely intent on
creating different kinds of science
programming putting together unusual
pieces to create an interesting
experience and we spoke to Oliver about
this and he got very excited about one
idea we had which was to pair him with
the Abyssinian Baptist Church Choir
and do a program on music and the brain
so we're up there at the church it's
filling in that people were just
squeezing into the pews every seat was
taken I'm about to go up on stage to
introduce the program and Oliver and
Oliver turns to me and he says to Jewish
boys about to give a tag-team sermon on
science at a Baptist Church he says you
know the Lord does work in mysterious
ways
Oliver Sacks you've written somewhere
about the fact that the increments of
things we see in a moment of time could
change the speed of them can change I
mean I don't quite understand that well
theoretically anyway well certainly well
William James thought they could change
theoretically depending on how many
events one could perceive in a second
how many events by that you mean
anything at all like I see that
spotlight whatever it made and it
doesn't have to be a theatre or a
concert just anything could be flashes
of light and in HD wells
deals with this in a fictional way in
the time machine and in stories he
whacks where he imagines that people can
be accelerated and then they will move
with great speed through the world and
the world will seem to be almost foes no
in slow motion and vice versa and I've
seen something similar I think in some
of my patients who may overlap with with
yours in in particular people with
Tourette syndrome who make sudden
movements and and sometimes sudden
noises can be very accelerated so
accelerated they can easily catch a fly
in midair can they really do that they
can really do it and if you ask them
they don't feel that they are very fast
they feel the flies are rather slow and
and that's so were the rest of us and
again if I can so they're fast the time
is the same but they're just speedier
they do more okay and experience more in
a particular time and William James
wrote in an allied context he said I'm
monkeys these people seem to us whilst
we seem to them reptilian now the term
reptilian rather unpleasant word
is sometimes used for the relative lack
or slowness of facial expression and of
movement generally
in people with parkinsonism and
parkinsonism is almost physiologically
the opposite of Tourette's
both of these depend on what one has
been looking at the amount of a
transmitter called dopamine and the
brain
so people with parkinsonian and
parkinsonism may move very slowly and
fear that the rest of us and that clocks
are going rather fast J newborn and I
met Oliver in 1996 when I had written a
book about me and my brother my brother
had been a mental patient most of his
adult life and I thought it would be a
book Oliver would find of interest if I
could get it to him I didn't know him so
I sent it to him care of the Bronx
Psychiatric Center and a few weeks later
I got a wonderful letter back from him
that he'd read my book said some very
kind things about it and then he said I
too have a brother like your brother
Robert and he's been through a lot of
the things your brother's been through
I'm wondering if I should show him your
book and that's he gave me his phone
number we talked and we became we've
been friends ever since I loved the fact
that from the very first letter he wrote
me about the book I'd written about me
and my brother imagining Robert that he
didn't send an email I never had an
email from him in old 20 years we knew
one another but he wrote letters and he
wrote them by hand they weren't typed
they would have editing within it he'd
be words crossed out and he'd put a
different word on top of it clearly he
reread them wanted to make sure that he
said what he wanted Oliver had a very
large effect on the way I saw my brother
the
I saw myself the way I saw myself in
relation to my brother and I believe he
had a great effect on anyone who read
him because he wrote about people who
were in effect the other he wrote about
people who were not like you and me
I think Oliver's great distinction was
his ability to join the sciences to the
humanities per se that is to say not
that they're different the science is a
part of the humanities but to be able as
a writer to make us understand how
wondrous and complicated the workings of
any human mind are the meanest of us has
something here that is more complicated
than anything in the known universe and
he enabled us to understand the ways
that difference an individuality could
show themselves forth I'm dr. mark hum
enough I first saw Oliver when I was a
medical student this was in the period
1970 to 1974 at Albert Einstein College
of Medicine up in the Bronx and it was
pointed out that he was an eccentric
member of the faculty
he wrote a motorcycle he wore a leather
jacket he wrote a motorcycle two rounds
but it was in an era of eccentricity
where amongst other things psychiatric
clinics were set up in pool halls in the
South Bronx and he was already
contemplating some mode of expression
for himself but it hadn't come about he
would submit many of these articles to
major American medical journals and they
would just be rejected as being too
journalistic too descriptive some of the
some of the review pieces he got back
said we don't agree with your statistics
there were no statistic
and what he did here was a it was it was
his discussion his perception of the
patient and the world of the patient and
how the patient functioned within the
realm of disease he suffered from Oliver
was able to take in almost any kind of
information I mean for all of her
extraneous information what most
physicians were considered to be
extraneous information well it was
anyone we considered to be extraneous
information in in any number of
capacities in which Oliver worked
operated was really just a father for
his imagination so you could see the the
heroism in in patients overcoming their
illness in in ways in which patients
worked around problems whether it was a
patient's obsessive thoughts or whether
it was difficulty with gait or whether
it was difficulty with movement how they
could fit this into their world and lead
lead lead a creative and productive life
despite with other impediments they ran
across and he attempted to assist them
and the enemy tried to a system of that
process and in many cases did my name is
John Hockenberry I've been an
acquaintance of Oliver Sacks exclusively
through the domain of journalism but we
were friends because I have a disability
and that's because his particular
curiosity about the details of my life
made him instantly interested in the
actually interesting things about me we
were friends from the first moment we
met Oliver Sacks talks as you've heard
tonight about flying about being freed
unburdened being able to fly and indeed
is the case that Oliver Sacks could go
places that normal humans could not go
and here's an example from a moment at
the World Science Festival in front of a
live audience a few years ago
I mean you you have had many
hallucinatory experiences some of which
were an accidental consequence of
substances that you were working with
and others more deliberate yeah
well the women there were many different
motives and was all it was all a long
time ago which as was all between 63 and
67 butts but certainly I'm one of them
I'd been puzzling about indigo indigo
was inserted into the spectrum by Newton
so was orange he felt there should be
seven colors as there are seven notes in
the musical scale but it seemed to me
that no two people agreed as to what
indigo was like and it was in fact felt
that the pigment derive from the indigo
plant was was not really integral and I
decided as I wanted to see indigo I
couldn't imagine it but I thought I
might be able to hallucinate it so I
built a sort of pharmacological
Launchpad now that that's different from
controlled substance okay
pharmacological launchpad I love that
this is a writer here so a base of
amphetamine and then some LSD and a
little little cannabis on top so I'll
take a shot of amphetamine with a LSD
chaser and a spot of cannabis and that
gets you well it's it's um got me a
fairly pickled I think stone just the
right
anyhow when when I felt ready I said I
want to see indigo now and as if thrown
by a paintbrush a trembling pear-shaped
blob of the most wonderful color
appeared on the wall indigo and it not
only seen been a wonderfully luminous
but it filled me with a sort of mystical
or almost religious joy I felt it was
numinous as well as luminous and
although I'm an old Jewish atheist I
thought this is the color of heaven so
as you can see Oliver Sacks
had a scientists I'll try anything once
spirit of adventure and I'll try some
things a few times spirit of mischief
all rolled into one
like most people I first met Oliver
Sacks in the pages of his many wonderful
books there his storytelling voice
seemed so unlike that of other writers
this methodical and reverential voice
could explain the miracles of the brain
by careful observations of its deficits
I could gasp inside to hear his stories
of what the brain could still do even
when it couldn't his was a voice clear
and exceptional like a French horn
soloing above an orchestra deliberate
and beautiful complex and full of warmth
but the actual voice of dr. Oliver Sacks
was almost a whisper deliberate and
clear this softer voice conveyed not
only his powers of observations but also
his empathy for his patients and one of
the most eloquent writers to ever speak
of the brain in person would say Blaine
almost an impediment spoken like a child
but brilliant in its own way after his
hearing loss became more pronounced the
whisper became deeper sometimes with the
touch of impatience he wanted us all to
listen closely and not just to him in
this moment of change in science and
medicine he was saying don't miss this
listen up he most of all celebrated his
patients he constantly wondered what it
would feel like to be them to feel their
incompleteness and to feel what it might
be like to have their brain function
restored was a dream of Oliver Sacks it
was another dream of seeing indigo I
suppose when he became a patient he
showed us all how the journey to death
need not diminish our curiosity one time
in an event in the streets the skies
opened up Oliver and I were on our way
to some panel discussion and while I
paid most attention to the roads and
puddles in front of my wheelchair
Oliver was silently staring at my
necktie eventually he said how did you
know that I love octopus your tie is
full of octopus I noticed for the very
first time that indeed my tie was full
of little line drawn cephalopods I said
happy to oblige
being with Oliver was to experience
moments like this always he would
discover something in front of your nose
I invited him to a conference 10 years
ago at MIT all about technology and
disability it's a wonderful wonderful
event presenters were all disabled
amputees brain injured scientists
working to make their limbs and brains
work better double leg amputee actress
and model Aimee Mullins brought a whole
crate of different legs that she was
showing off Oliver loved that a young
man with cerebral palsy played his own
music that he composed Oliver couldn't
have been happy to her happier to have
been a part of it he whispered to me at
the end that he felt like one of the
gang
I've always believed he said that
patients do the best research you know
the trick is getting them to show it to
you Oliver Sacks doctor patient did he
see a difference I'm Isabel rappin I'm a
child neurologist and retired from
Albert Einstein College of Medicine
I met Oliver Sacks probably the first
month that he came to Einstein in the
fall of 1965 and we've been friends ever
since I think that it was his interest
in the individual patient and the
concern about the individual
consequences of neurologic illness
rather than an neurologic illness per se
that led him into the direction that his
career took and and into his writings
which of course have turned out to
because of his talent have turned out to
be so dramatic l-dopa was very helpful
to patients with parkinsonism he made
observations that no neurologist had
ever seen he observed when he gave it to
his post encephalitic Parkinson patients
that they developed yes some of them
woke up after years of being barely
communicative frozen in place suddenly
were able to move and become lively
again does he ever speak to you
personally
not in words no change day to 9:00
your patients doctor haven't moved in
decades what I believe but I know these
people are alive inside but how do you
know that doctor and knowing the 200
milligrams he showed no response maybe
he needs more maybe he needs less
Oliver went from a person that people
sort of looked at and didn't take too
seriously
as to what Neurology ended up realizing
was the best ambassador at Emma had my
name is Tobias picker I met Oliver for
the first time in my own apartment
actually I gave a dinner party for
Oliver which was arranged for by a
mutual friend of ours ed Weinberg and
that was about 25 years ago or so and I
was interested in meeting Oliver because
I had been diagnosed with Tourette's
syndrome very late I guess I was my mid
30s so because when I was a child when
the symptoms started there was there was
no way it could be diagnosed so it was
swept under the rug and also the big
elephant in the room for my whole life
until I became aware of Oliver's
writings about it so as we moved in
similar circles
he knew writers that I knew as a
composer I wanted to talk to him so he
came to dinner he was very helpful to me
because he could talk about what he what
he was observing in a way that that made
me understand how I was being perceived
by the by the outside world in a way
that reassured me that I I am wasn't
that I didn't have to be as ashamed of
of having this um this thing as I had
been as a child growing up with it it I
think I think Oliver said once not to me
but I've read this about a quote of his
the question isn't not what disease does
the person have the question is what
person does the disease have so I had a
very difficult childhood and and stayed
with me
it stayed with me for well that it will
stay with me forever
but knowing Oliver being able to to be
to spend time with Oliver and to be just
to be in the presence of his greatness
made me feel better about myself
in rereading the book it dawned on me
that this this material is is is
terrific terrific inspiration for dance
because it's all it took if it can be
all it can be read as a as a study in in
movement and the absence of movement
you
I try and live with my patients in a way
I used to live next door to the hospital
at that time and sort of share their
experiences and joys and griefs but it
was it was horrible to see Leonard lose
what he had and his his desperation and
has hopelessness and I I felt guilty in
a sense I thought um could I have known
that this would happen should should one
have animated him have awakened him in
the first place and your answer was my
answer or the patient's answer in
general was yes and they would go ahead
and say further if only this had been
available 20 years ago before we'd lost
so much of life and lost and had so much
damage in our brains and indeed had this
occurred 20 years ago the things
wouldn't have been so tantalizing people
with ordinary Parkinson's disease get
get a far longer good period home on the
drug
Daniel Frank I'm the editorial director
of Pantheon books the way Oliver worked
was unique and yes it was completely
different than anything I had seen
before the other aspect of Oliver was
that not only would there be the pages
posted on a bulletin board there would
be a chalkboard or a magic marker board
with all the possible subjects or topics
possible or during possible organization
and even you know when I saw those they
had already been revised two or three
times and it was a matter of like where
are we now and so the conversation I
always felt like when I would arrive
there this is what we're thinking now
and so I quickly learned all right this
is now it could be different by the end
of our visit it could be different
tomorrow but it was always for me it was
always this chance to hear Oliver
thinking out loud about a subject about
how he was moving through a book what
made that subject work for him and I
mean what you discovered in editing is
that there isn't necessarily a right or
wrong way there is a way of you know
telling a story that's compelling and
that's what you wanted to do each time
it's sort of fun if you're in the in the
creative business it's fun to play with
fast horses maybe it'd be one thing if
you were good at something and you found
people who are as good as you or less
good as you and you mentor them or
whatever and that would be like
clippity-clop clippity-clop but if you
find friends who are better than you and
Oliver was smarter I mean really smart
just almost effortlessly he could
consume all kinds of information just
very very easily and he remembered it
and then he could weigh it and measure
it and balance it and he could listen
and he could write and he had a sense it
beauty had crazy eyes for seeing and a
pretty big heart and
I think when you when you pal up with
somebody who's so much better than you
are in every category and you kind of
know that you'll never be you could
never get there it makes you as good as
you can possibly be
and so the the cool part for me was
getting to keep company with the fast is
one of the fastest horses I'd ever met
I'm addicted to patients like I can't do
without them I need to have the feeling
of of these other lives which would
become a part of my own empathy isn't
enough I wish I could be in their shoes
or know more exactly what it's like
sitting at this tremendous motion and I
know your animal paintings and
sculptures - its is a sort of energized
state in which there is a sort of
convulsive energy which especially takes
the form of excessive movement of sudden
movement of compulsive movement tics of
touching of compulsive noises sometimes
from pulse of thoughts I think with
Shane I have never seen on the one hand
such severity or maybe intensity of
turrets but with such with such a sort
of grace of living and accepting and
sort of using it I mean I think sort of
sort of inspiring to see him to let
something bullies or use as you do you
think you have ways of using it you
translate I think in my art in which
sort of ways you know III can make I
don't know because I I like because of
because I know I like the touch all you
think that I can I can feed that or
unleashing unleash it is the way I know
I know that when I found sculpture I
found I found that I was it was
it was perfect it was it was that that
was my my world I felt at home my name
is Maria Popova I read and I write and I
write about what I read on a website
called brain pickings I came to dr.
Sachs's work fairly late laid both in my
life and late in his career I grew up
very far away and his books didn't make
it to the other side of the Iron Curtain
where I grew up and I found them as an
adult and I just fell in love with the
way that he sees the world and he's able
to articulate what he sees well beyond
science
I think dr. sacks figured himself out in
the act of writing and there was
something contagious about that there
was kind of intense curiosity with which
he examined what was on his mind and the
nature of the mind all at once and
pulled you into that so that you would
examine your own mind and its nature in
the act of reading you know it's
interesting to consider how he saw
people the people that he worked with
the so-called patients in a way that's
increasingly countered to how they're
seen by the medical and scientific
culture of today where patients are very
often reduced to data points and yet
here he was telling us that the interior
lives of people matter and that their
their singular and dignified and
different and the humanity that sprang
from each interaction that he had with a
person not just a patient that's
something that is so important to
preserve and he's kind of the patron
saint of this way of treating human
beings my name is Steve Silverman and I
met Oliver originally because Kate Edgar
his assistant got in touch with me to
tell me that Oliver had really enjoyed
an article that I wrote called the geek
syndrome in Wired magazine which was one
of the first articles to
look at autism and high-tech communities
like Silicon Valley
what made oliver z' work on autism so
important was that for decades autistic
people had been identified as not having
the essential qualities that make us
human so they were defined by clinicians
and psychiatrists as for instance
lacking empathy or lacking the capacity
for humor or lacking the capacity to
love their own parents and all of that's
wrong his portrait of Temple Grandin in
an anthropologist on Mars was the most
humane and deep portrait of an autistic
adult that had ever been written in
history
and believe me I read all the stuff that
came before it and so Oliver simply by
being open to being surprised by Temple
was able to pick up on her humanity in
such a way that he could render this
fully human portrait my name is Temple
Grandin I am a professor of animal
science at Colorado State University now
of course I have known about all of her
sexist work long before I ever met him
and then one day I got a call that he
wanted to come out and talk to me about
autism they just wanted to research some
things about autism with me and I set it
up and he came out and I was very fun
not talking with Oliver and one of the
things I remember the most is he wanted
to go up to the National Park and I had
to stop him from my jumping in the river
Oliver you're gonna go over a dam if you
jump in that River
no you absolutely cannot go in that
River and I stopped him from doing that
well I think all of our gave the so I'd
say the neurotypical world insight and
how different kinds of minds perceive
the world he was a great observer oh
there were some people in the medical
community that criticized them because
what he was doing is observation but
observation is part of science I used to
fight with my major professor when I was
getting my PhD all the time he'd say
well you got to do controlled experiment
otherwise it's not science and I'd go
okay what's astronomy but in order to
have a hypothesis you've got to observe
first and Oliver was a great observer he
definitely did not he definitely did not
write like a scientist one of the big
fights we got in science if some
hardcore scientist say well unless you
got a control group and experimental
group it's not science
Oliver was an observer an observation is
a very important part of science there's
no way that you're going to have a
hypothesis until you have an observation
to make the hypothesis so you can do the
other controlled experiments the
observers actually are the leaders well
I think his book suggests going to
enlighten you know a lot of young
doctors are gonna read us books I mean a
lot of family members read his books I'm
people parents of autistic children have
read the article he did about me you
know he's you know he's gonna live on in
his writings and he wrote down
everything before he died he was writing
right up until he died hi I'm Connie
Tomino and a friend of Oliver's for over
35 years how does music affect the brain
that was actually the question that
started our friendship so many years ago
in 1998 I was working in a small nursing
home with people with end stages of
Alzheimer's disease and dementia people
I was told had no recognition of
themselves or anything around them for
all intents and purposes they had no
brains at all at least that's what the
doctors were telling me and yet each one
of those individuals I could find a song
a piece of music that could bring them
to life to make
connection to have them interact with me
in the world around them in 1980 I was
offered a full-time position at Beth
Abraham Hospital and within the first
week there I received the manila
envelope in interoffice mail addressed
to the music therapists and inside that
envelope was a torn piece of loose-leaf
paper with words scribbled on it in
magic marker every sickness is a musical
problem every cure a musical solution
Novalis welcome Ally I soon discovered
that Ali was the neurologist the staff
neurologist at that Abraham and of
course I started stalking his his office
just for the chance to meet him in
person one day I saw a patient that I
had started the working way a woman who
was rigid pretty much non-responsive
nonverbal at least was we were told she
was nonverbal but she did respond to
gospel music and when I sang those songs
not only did she sing along but she
became animated and started talking
so I told all of her I said dr. Sachs
you have to see her sing you have to see
her speak and he says come show me come
show me and I sat next to him and he
gently held her hand and I sang and she
came to life and he was amazed how is
this possible so immediately he reached
over to his desk he had a stack of EEG s
and he pulled out one and he says look
at this look at this irregularly EEG
this is Ed he has Parkinson's he says
but look at this this is n this is Ed
thinking about music look how beautiful
that AG is from then on I started
getting notes into all of his medical
referrals for me to look at how the
person responded when I played did they
tap their foot could they sing could
they initiate the word what did it look
like again I started to observe every
single thing I did to the music what was
it about music that enable these people
to come to life to become whole again
and he would I would try to talk as much
as possible but that work it was really
difficult he lived on City Island he had
just bought a home back then and I lived
very close by so he started to invite
me over in the evening for dinner just
to talk with whether we know about music
what does it look like how do I patients
respond and for every question I had and
I was loaded with them he would pull a
book from one of his shelves
Henry had healings Jackson every single
question I had he had a quote from some
book that he had the first edition of we
tried we knew that there was something
about music in the brain we knew that
there was some networks elements that
aroused fundamental function in these
individuals who seemed otherwise
unreachable and in the early 80s we
actually tried to meet with scientists
to see if we can encourage them to study
music in the brain but they said the
field of neurosciences is way too new
and music so complex how could we
possibly study that but all of us
started writing these case studies and
he started putting them out in the
London Review of Books in the New York
Review of Books and the literary world
as you know started to take notice and I
remember a time when Susan Sontag
invited him to speak at Cooper Union and
Oliver wasn't yet ready for primetime
public speaker and he said Connie please
come along with me please come along
with me and we we went there and I spent
an hour before him of course this was
pre Kate days so he would drag me along
on all this talks and he said please
let's go over the patients whether they
look like what should I say what what's
going on and of course he wrote all of
his notes on his arm and my only my only
job he told me was to sit in the front
so he could see me and any time he
started to stammer just go like this so
he would look at his arm and get back on
track
his work the movies started to gain much
recognition and the administration
started to recognize the importance of
the work that we were trying to do to
understand how to reach people who
seemed otherwise unreachable and for
whom any medical science and the medical
community had deemed at the end stages
of life but yet these people were still
very much full with life and we could
animate them and
them into the present so our
administration helped us found the
Institute for music in neurologic
function in 1995 as a bridge between the
worlds of neuroscience and clinical
music therapy to form dialogues across
these disciplines to not only advance
the scientific knowledge and about how
music affects human function but also to
help clinical music therapists apply it
in more efficacious ways there were no
words that I can say right now that can
tell you the depths of my gratitude and
love for Oliver not only for what he has
given me as a clinician and in our
friendship but what he has given the
world as you've heard about bringing the
humanists back to the individuals that
we take care of to recognizing the
potential in in those people as well and
also bringing the face and knowledge
about the field of music therapy and the
importance of that work to help so many
people and it's it's very appropriate
and they I can demonstrate well you'll
get a chance to actually witness the
importance of music especially how music
affects the brain as I welcome and you
hear and listen to Erik Jordan
metropolitan opera singer who's also a
stroke survivor who regained his speech
and ability to talk to through the
extraordinary power of music
well thank you everybody yes I'm a
stroke survivor and a friend of mine let
me the book called the man who mistook
his wife for a hat and I thought myself
well myself should be an opera as and
this - chamber opera and my character
dr. P suffers from visual agnosia he has
illusions nations without need drugs and
and this is a dream come true
thank you can't Connie for reaching out
to me to sing for everybody here you are
all of observers right and I've had a
quick story to share before I sing in
the deli somewhere and then by the net
didn't the met I couldn't speak my order
so I sang it I said I like a whole-wheat
footlong with roast beef with mustard
sauce with lettuce and tomatoes please
and the dude across the counter is like
who's who I could do one of those thing
is singing it singing order okay well
give this guy some horseradish and more
sprays and this New York City right so
it's wackadoo central it's good it's a
good way you know so before I keep on
jibber jabbering let's make some music
Oh
he has a terrace hi
Oh
Oh
Oh
Combee lost this emptiness
is it dipped a section finished we thank
you and await diagnosis where's my head
my hat my hat mistake
that fool you
I'm feign right and I had the great
pleasure to be Oliver's piano teacher
for about seven years when we met Oliver
was about 75 and he had had his last
piano lesson when he was 12 he had
adored his childhood teacher and was
really hesitant even after all those
decades to study with anyone else this
is just an example of the depth of his
loyalty to the people in his life and I
was soon to feel that loyalty myself we
became fast friends very quickly and he
was a lot of fun his playing style was
pretty unique when I first met him he
would raise his arms high and proceeded
to bounce off the keys as though they
were on fire he would clamp the pedal
down and play everything staccato and
Forte if he ran out of fingers he would
simply flip his hand over and a sort of
Chico Marx maneuver and use his index
finger he played with a lot of a LAN he
was not crazy about music after 1920 or
so he was very fond of Debussy but that
was about as modern as he was willing to
get I convinced him to play some Bartok
Romanian dances but I think that was
partly because he'd heard his father
playing them he had a very personal
association with many pieces of music
and he always expressed interest in
lists because he remembered his brother
David playing list
I was always amazed at his perseverance
with the piano in face of great physical
obstacles his back was in terrible pain
he had bad insomnia and his thumbs were
distorted by arthritis and he was blind
in one eye so he he had to have many
many cushions sitting on the bench in
order to be comfortable and he had to
enlarge every page of his music for the
pieces that we worked on even then he
often had to resort to a magnifying
glass that he kept on the side of the
piano to peer at the score so it was
very difficult for him but he didn't let
him he didn't let that slow him down at
all
I tribute my mother with being my first
music teacher she grew up in a farm in
Pennsylvania and when she was a teenager
she was the rehearsal pianist at the
Methodist Church in the town of booth
when my parents always felt that it was
important to be surrounded by music we
all studied instruments we all played
instruments by being surrounded with
music it helped us become whole people
my mother used to gather us around the
piano and she played for the Methodist
hymnal and my brothers and sister and I
would would sing from the Methodist
hymnal and we would be taught harmonies
at a very early age my mother was always
the sharpest knife in the drawer she was
very funny
very smart but she began to lose her
memory when my father passed away 18
years ago and one of the beautiful
things about living with someone with
dementia is that it's all about the
present moment the past is history the
future has no frame of reference so it's
really what's in front of you the clouds
passing in the sky the softness of a cat
a beautiful sunset
my mother three years ago when she had
to have 24-hour care and could no longer
live with us moved to the actors home in
Englewood New Jersey and when I go and
visit her sometimes I can get her to sit
at the piano and she'll play from the
Methodist hymnal the very same Methodist
hymnal that she taught me to sing from
as a child and when she plays the piano
and we sing together in harmony
suddenly I'm a child again and she's a
young mother and were in the moment and
in the moment it becomes transcendent
and I have a glimpse of that which is
eternal a glimpse of forever
my life goes on in every song bobberts
levitation
I hear the clear though far off him that
hails a new creation through strife I
hear the music how can I keep from
singing what all my joys and comforts
died I know the truth is worth all the
darkness gather round songs in one night
it giveth no bow to that rock I'm
how can I give
I lift my eyes the clouds will thin I
see the blue and every day the pathways
smooth since first I learn to love it
appears within makes fresh my heart Oh
how can I keep
how can I give
I keep from see
so my name is Slava santarilla and I
know Oliver for many many years and
actually my first experience with him
was a little bit odd and funny at the
same time he approached me at the pool
he was waiting on the side I was
teaching and he was waiting at the side
on the side and when I stopped he
approached me and he said I want you to
be my coach so my first response was why
me and he said because you're the best
okay the funny thing that two months
later he done absolutely he refused to
do anything I told him to do so it's get
to the point when I said Oliver if you
think I'm the best why you're not doing
anything and if you know everything why
you need me it's not just I teach him
how to swim he actually teach me how it
should be a better coach how to be a
better instructor and I find out because
I thought at the beginning that he is
very stubborn don't wanna learn anything
new and I was so wrong really
I think he's the most open person I ever
met and he is really eager to learn
something new and with an marvelous
wonderful job together but every time
literally every single time when he will
come for practicing she'll be excited
excited that he will be in the water
that he will do again something and he
will feel very very free and it's it's a
very rare thing yes he definitely was in
love with with water my name is Ian
sample and Oliver's personal trainer
people say like what was Oliver like and
I say he's like a Renaissance man where
you don't really see too many people
like that you don't see too many people
that are a marathon swimmer that could
squat 600 pounds which is still super
impressive I don't know if anyone knows
how much the weight that really is but
it's insane and also was a scientist and
a published writer and author is just
such an amazing person he could look at
an element whether it's a rock whether
it's I turn 33 or 32 and he gives me the
element like gallium or something like
that or he just looked at something that
I think is really simple with such big
fascination and such big eyes and he was
I mean he's looked at these things for
over probably 70 years and he still was
so fascinated by that
science important why a science
important because it gives one a picture
of the world I think which one can't get
in any other way no it's not the only
picture and it must be the only picture
I mean I think when one needs to sort of
read the poets and listen to music and
maybe be religious when one needs every
sort of picture but I think one has to
have the scientific picture as well and
one always did and even if there were no
formal laws without science people would
never have have made fire would never
have made clothes would never built
houses would never discovered
agriculture civilization errs is partly
dependent on science my name is Laura
Schneider I'm a writer and I'm a
philosophy professor at st. John's
University I later found that Oliver's
favorite philosopher was David Hume who
the 18th century philosopher David Hume
who said that he wanted to be
essentially the Newton of the moral
realm David Hume wanted to take the
study of human nature and make it as
important as the study of physics was in
that period of time which was so soon
after Isaac Newton had revolutionized
physics and I always felt that Oliver's
work was like that he wanted to elevate
the study of the human elements of
neurological disease he wanted to look
at the human dimension and make that a
subject of interest to the physician as
much as the physical dimension of the
disease and to me that's a very generous
way of looking at neurological illness I
sometimes felt that I had left England
in an underhand way I'd had the best of
English education had absorbed best of
English dictionary's the habits and
traditions of a thousand years and here
I was taking this precious mental cargo
everything that had been invested in me
out
country without so much as a thank you
or goodbye I did not seek American
citizenship
it was happy to have a green card to be
accounted a resident alien this accorded
with how I felt at least for much of the
time
a friendly observant alien noting
everything around me but without civic
responsibilities such as voting or jury
duty or need to affiliate myself with
the country's policies or politics I
often felt as Temple Grandin said of
herself that I was anthropologist on
Mars and then in June of 2008 to my
surprise I heard that my name was in the
Queen's Birthday Honours List that I was
to become a commander of the British
Empire
the term commander tickled me I could
not imagine myself as a commander on the
bridge of a destroyer or a battleship
but I was curiously and rather deeply
moved by the honor though I'm not given
to formal clothes or other formalities
normally my clothes are sloppy and
decrepit and I have only one suit
I enjoy the formality is embarking on
Paris being instructed how to bow how to
walk backwards before the Queen how to
await her taking once and or addressing
one the royal person was not to be
touched or spoken to and bidden I was
half afraid that I would do something
awful like faint of heart right in front
of the Queen but all went well during
the ceremony I was very impressed by the
Queen's stamina
by the time I was called up she had been
standing erect without support for more
than two hours there were 200 honorees
that day she spoke to me briefly but
warmly asked me what I was working on I
had the feeling of a very decent
friendly person to the sense of humor It
was as if she and England were saying
you have done useful honorable work come
home
all is forgiven
they called me in Keith as a boy and I
still seem to get as ink-stained as I
did 70 years ago I started keeping
journals when I was 14 and at last count
had nearly a thousand they come in all
shapes and sizes from little pocket ones
which I carry around with me to enormous
stones
I always keep my side for dweebs as well
as nighttime thoughts and I try to have
one by the swimming pool or the lake
side of the seashore
swimming tube is very productive of
thoughts which I must write especially
if they present themselves as they
sometimes do in the form of whole
sentences or paragraphs while writing my
league book I drew heavily on the detail
journals
I had kept as a patient in 1974 what
Hakka journal 2 relied on my hand with
notebooks but for the most part I really
look at the journals I've kept for the
greater part of a lifetime the act of
writing is itself enough
it serves to clarify my thoughts and
feelings the act of writing is an
integral part of my mental life ideas
emerge are shaped in the act of writing
my journals are not written for others
nor do I usually look at them myself but
they are a special indispensable form of
talking to myself I am a storyteller for
better and for worse I suspect that the
feeling for stories for narrative is a
universal human disposition going
without powers of language consciousness
of self and autobiographical memory the
act of writing when it goes well gives
me a pleasure a joy unlike any other it
takes me to another place whatever my
subject where I am totally absorbed and
oblivious to distracting thoughts Wow
his preoccupations or indeed the passage
of time in these rare heavenly states of
mind in these rare heavenly states of
mind I may write non-stop until I can no
longer see the paper
only then do I realize that evening has
come and I've been writing all day over
a lifetime I've written millions of
words but the act of writing seems as
fresh and as much fun as when I started
it nearly 70 years ago
needless to say I mean I'm for years
I've been in an admirer an incredible
admirer of all of his accomplishments
but but that's not been an obstacle in
our friendship you know I haven't you
know people think of all of us acts all
of the sides all of the sides to be a
little sex is my friend but I know very
very well who's been in my house
innumerable times who knows all my kids
who knows my husband well I know about
his family we've talked about all sorts
of things about his family I mean you
know it's my friends in my heart I think
however was literally able to expand the
reach of everybody's neighbourhood and
to include people who had been excluded
and that's you know he was a complicated
guy but that's an achievement it was
just such a pleasure to work with Oliver
via music that we became such good
friends through that medium
I learned so much from him and I was
very grateful for that time with him oh
if I could talk with Oliver now or send
him a letter I would say Oliver let's go
out and have some sushi and I want to
hear about your next book I'm what are
you working on he was a presence in my
life for 20 years I learned so much from
him I go back and read his books
dozens of letters he wrote to me because
we would change exchange books and
articles all the time and I'm grateful
for the example I think I would tell
them that I'm excited to go to Mexico in
three weeks I'm gonna go snorkeling and
scuba diving and I'm gonna take the
wetsuit that he let me have and I'll
take lots of pictures for him if I could
say one thing to Oliver write him a
letter Oliver wherever you are I would
say thank you and I think I would also
tell him that
sitting under these lights being filmed
talking about him had an oddly calming
effect on my tics such that for the most
part for most of the interviews I felt
just like anybody else I just want to
say that I love him I love him not just
as my student I love him for who he is
and because he it's not just me I think
you've touched so many hearts in so many
ways it's a wonderful ability thank you
for teaching many a generation of
writers that it was important to look at
the human dimension of science and it
was important to bring science to a
broader public because that's the only
way the people will become
scientifically literate and be able to
make the decisions that we need to make
in the world today I would say that the
last message that I would have written
to Oliver would have just been thank you
and it's very very rare to watch a man
grow closer and closer to death and have
his eyes get wider and wider open as he
moves towards that place I've never seen
anything like it I would say Oliver was
was really one of the best of the
physicians I've run across ever and in
any institutions treated his patients
respectfully and was able from listening
closely and from pulling details of what
the patient had to say and from
listening to things that many people
were concerned to be extraneous was able
to propel the science of Medicine
in in the great fashion in ways that one
should try to replicate my last exchange
was actually with the computer in my
kitchen crying trying so hard I couldn't
even figure out how to print it out
reading the last piece that he wrote I
was crying so hard that's kind of what I
feels my last exchange reading that New
York Times article on my computer and I
was just putting my head on the desk and
crying James Baldwin used to say that
the poets by which he meant the artist
is the only person who knows what it's
like for anybody who comes to this
planet to survive it what it's like to
die to have somebody die what it's like
to be glad and in a way dr. Sachs was
this kind of poet who was able to get to
that inner most universal human
experience through the very personal
experience of his patients and of
himself and articulate what that's like
what it's like to be here what it's like
to live and why
you
you